[Music]
the first idea I'd like to suggest is
that we all love music a great deal it
means a lot to us but music is even more
powerful if you don't just listen to it
but you make it yourself that's my first
idea and we all know about the Mozart
Effect the idea that's been around for
the last five to ten years that just by
listening to music or by playing music
to your baby in vitro that it'll raise
our IQ points 10 20 30 % great idea but
it doesn't work at all so you can't just
listen to music you have to make it
somehow and I'd add to that that it's
not just making it but everybody each of
us everybody in the world has the power
to create and be part of music in a very
dynamic way and that's one of the main
parts of my work so at the MIT Media Lab
for quite a while now we've been engaged
in a field called active music what are
all the possible ways that we can think
of to get everybody in the middle of a
musical experience not just listening
but making music and we started by
making instruments for some of the
world's greatest performers we call
these hyper instruments for yo-yo ma
Peter Gabriel Prince orchestras rock
bands instruments where they're all
kinds of sensors built right into the
instrument so the instrument knows how
it's being played and just by changing
the interpretation and the feeling I can
turn my cello into a voice or into a
whole Orchestra or into something never
nobody's ever heard before when we
started making these I started thinking
well why can't we make wonderful
instruments like that for everybody
people who aren't fantastic yo-yo Ma's
or Prince's so we've made a whole series
of instruments one of the largest
collections is called the brain opera
it's a whole Orchestra of about a
hundred instruments all designed for
anybody to play using natural skill so
you can play a video game drive through
a piece of music use your body gesture
to control huge masses of sound touch a
special surface to make melodies use
your voice to make a whole aura and when
we make the brain opera we invite the
public to come in to try these
instruments and then collaborate with us
to help make each performance of the
brain opera we toured that for a long
time it's now permanently in Vienna
where we built a museum around it and
that led to something which you probably
do know guitar hero came out of our lab
and my two teenage daughters and most of
the students at the MIT Media Lab are
proof that if you make the right kind of
interface
people are really interested in being in
the middle of a piece of music and
playing it over and over and over again
so the model works but it's only the tip
of the iceberg because my second idea is
that it's not enough just to want to
make music in something like Guitar Hero
and music is very fun but it's also
transformative it's very very important
music can change your life more than
almost anything it can change your the
way you communicate with others it can
change your body it can change your mind
so we were trying to go to the next step
of how you build on top of something
like Guitar Hero we are very involved in
education have a long-term project
called toy Symphony where we make all
kinds of instruments that are also
addictive but for little kids so the
kids will fall in love with making music
want to spend their time doing it and
then we'll demand to know how it works
how to make more how to create so we
make squeezy instruments like these
music shapers that measure the
electricity and your fingers beat bugs
that let you tap in rhythms they gather
your rhythm and like hot potato you send
your rhythm to your friends who then
have to imitate or respond to what
you're doing and a software package
called hyper score which lets anybody
use lines in color to make quite
sophisticated music extremely easy to
use but once you use it you can go quite
deep music in any style and then by
pressing a button it turns into music
notation so that live musicians can now
play your pieces we've had good enough
really very powerful effects with kids
around the world and now people of all
ages using hyper score so we've gotten
more and more interested in using these
kind of creative creative activities in
a much broader context for all kinds of
people who don't usually have the
opportunity to make music so one of the
growing fields that we're working on at
the Media Lab right now is music mind
and health a lot of you have probably
seen Oliver Sacks his wonderful new book
called music Ophelia it's on sale in the
bookstore it's a great book if you
haven't seen it it's worth reading he's
a pianist himself and he details his
whole career of looking at an observing
incredibly powerful effects that music
have had on people's lives in unusual
situations so we know for instance that
music is almost always the last thing
that people with advanced Alzheimer's
can still respond to you may be many of
you have noticed this with loved ones
you can find somebody who can't
recognize their face in the mirror can't
tell anyone in their family you can
still find a shard of music that that
person will jump out of the chair and
start singing and with
you can bring back parts of people's
memories and personalities music is the
best way to restore speech to people
who've lost it through strokes movement
to people with Parkinson's disease it's
very powerful for depression
schizophrenia and many many things so
we're working on understanding those
underlying principles and then building
activities which will let music really
improve people's health and we do this
in many ways we work with many different
hospitals one of them is right near
Boston called Tewksbury hospital it's a
long term State Hospital where several
years ago we started working with hyper
score and patients with physical and
mental disabilities this has become a
central part of the treatment at
Tewksbury hospital so everybody there
clamors to work on musical activities
it's the activity that seems to
accelerate people's treatment the most
and it also brings the entire hospital
together as a kind of musical community
I want to show you a quick video of some
of this work before I go on
[Applause]
[Music]
manipulating each other's rhythms it's a
real experience not only to learn how to
play and listen to rhythms but to train
your musical memory and playing music in
a group music to shape it themselves
change it to experiment with it to make
their own music so hyper score lets you
start from scratch very quickly
everybody can experience music in a
profound way we just have to make
different tools
[Applause]
the third idea I wanted to share with
you is that music paradoxically I think
even more than words it's one of the
very best ways we have of showing who we
really are
I love giving talks although strangely I
feel more nervous giving talk than
playing music if I were here playing
cello or playing on a synth or sharing
my music with you I'd be able to show
things about myself that I can't tell
you in words more personal things
perhaps deeper things I think that's
true for for many of us and I wanted to
give you two examples of how music is
one of the most powerful interfaces we
have from ourselves to the outside world
the first is a really crazy project that
we're building right now called death
and the powers and it's a big opera one
of the larger opera projects going on in
the world right now and it's about a man
rich successful powerful who wants to
live forever so he figures out a way to
download himself into his environment
actually do a series of books now but so
this guy wants to live forever he
downloads himself into his environment
the main singer disappears for at the
beginning of the Opera and the entire
stage becomes the main character it
becomes his legacy
and the Opera is about what we can share
what we can pass on to others to the one
people we love and what we can't every
object in the Opera comes alive and as a
gigantic music instrument like the
chandelier takes up the whole stage
looks like a chandelier but it's
actually a robotic music instrument
gigantic piano strings each string is
controlled with little robotic elements
either their little bows that stroke the
strings propellers that tickle the
strings acoustic signals that vibrate
the strings we also have an army of
robots on stage these robots are the
kind of intermediary between the main
character Simon Powers and his family
there are a whole series of them kind of
like a Greek chorus they observe the
action we've designed these square
robots that we're testing right now at
MIT called opera BOTS these opera bots
follow my music they follow the
characters they're smart enough we hope
not to bump into each other they go off
on their own and then they can also when
you snap line up exactly the way you'd
like to even though they're cubes they
actually have a lot of personality
[Music]
the largest set piece on the Opera is
it's called the system it's a series of
books every single book is robotic so
they all move they all make sound and
when you put them all together they turn
to these walls which have the gesture
and the personality of Simon powers so
he's disappeared but the whole physical
environment becomes this person this is
how he's chosen to represent himself the
books also have high pact LEDs on spines
so it's all a display and here's the
great baritone James Madalena as he
enters the system this is a sneak
preview
[Music]
[Music]
this premiers in Monaco and since
September 2009 if any chance you can't
make it another idea with this project
here's this guy building his legacy
through this very unusual form through
music and through the environment but
we're also making this available both
online and in public spaces as a way of
each of us to use music and images from
our lives to make our own legacy tour
make a legacy of someone we love so
instead of being Grand Opera this opera
will turn into what we're thinking of as
personal opera if you're gonna make
personal opera what about a personal
instrument everything I've shown you so
far whether it's a hyper cello for yo-yo
ma or a squeezy toy for a child the
instruments stay the same and are
valuable for a certain class of person a
virtuoso a child but what if I could
make an instrument that could be adapted
to the way I personally behave to the
way my hands work to what I do very
skillfully perhaps to what I don't do so
skillfully I think this is the future of
interface is the future of music the
future of instruments and I'd like now
to invite two very special people on a
stage so I can give you an example of
what personal instruments might be like
so can you give a hand to Adam Boulanger
PhD student from the MIT Media Lab and
Dan Elsi dan thanks thanks to Ted and to
Bombardier flex Jet Dan is here with us
today all the way from Tewksbury he's a
resident to Tewksbury Hospital this is
by far the farthest eat straight from
Tewksbury hospital I can tell you that
because it's motivated to meet with you
today and show you his own music so
first of all let Dan you want to say hi
to everyone tell tell everyone who you
are
hello my name is Dan LC I am 34 years
old and I have cerebral palsy I have
always loved music and I am excited to
be able to conduct my own music with
this new software and we're really
excited to have you here
[Applause]
so we met Dan about three years ago
three and a half years ago when we
started working at Tewksbury everybody
we met there was fantastic did fantastic
music dan had never made music before
and it turned out he was really
fantastic at it he's a born composer
he's very shy - so turned out he's a
fantastic composer and over the last few
years has been a constant collaborator
of ours has made many many pieces makes
his own CDs actually it's quite well
known in the Boston area mentors people
at the hospital and children locally in
how to make their own music and I'll let
Adam tell you so Adams a PhD student at
MIT and expert in music technology and
medicine and Adam and Dan had become
close collaborators what Adams been
working on for this last period is not
only how to have Dan be able to easily
to make his own pieces but how we can
perform his piece using this kind of
personal instrument so you want to say a
little bit about how you guys work yes
um
so Todd and I entered into a discussion
following the Tewksbury work and it was
really about how Dan is an expressive
person and he's an intelligent and
creative person and it's in his face
it's in his breathing it's in his eyes
how come he can't perform one of his
pieces of music that's our
responsibility and it doesn't make sense
so we started developing a technology
that will allow him with nuance with
precision with control and despite his
physical disability to be able to do
that to be able to perform at his piece
of music so the process and the
technology basically first we need an
engineering solution so you know we have
a FireWire camera it looks at an
infrared pointer we went with the type
of sort of gesture metaphor that Dan was
already used to with his talking with
his speaking controller and this is
actually the least interesting part of
the work you know is the design process
we needed an input when you continuous
tracking in a software we look at the
types of shapes he's making but then was
the really interesting aspect of the
work following the engineering part
where basically we're coding over Dan
shoulder at the hospital extensively to
figure out you know how does Dan move
what's useful to him as an expressive
motion
you know what's his metaphor of
performance what types of things does
find important to control and convey in
a piece of music and so all the
parameter fitting and really the
technology was stretched at that point
to fit just Dan and you know I think
this is a perspective shift it's not
that our technologies they provide
access they allow us to create pieces of
creative work but what about expression
what about that moment when an artist
delivers that piece of work you know
door technologies allow us to express do
they provide structure for us to do that
and you know that's a personal
relationship to expression that is
lacking in the technological sphere so
you know with Dan we needed a new design
process a new engineering process to
sort of discover his movement and his
path to expression that allow him to
perform and so that's what we'll do
today so let's do it
so Dan you want to what tell everybody
what you want to what what you're gonna
play now this is my equal song so Dan's
gonna play a piece of his called my
Eagle song in fact this is the score for
Dan's piece completely composed by Dan
in hyper score and so he can use his
infrared tracker to go directly into
hyper score he's incredibly fast out of
two faster than I am in fact it's really
modest to know something go in make you
in hyper score you start out by making
melodies and rhythms he can even place
those exactly where he wants each one
gets a color it goes back into the
composition window draws the lines
places everything the way he wants to
looking at the hyper score you can see
it also you can see where the sections
are something might continue for a while
change get really crazy and then end up
with a with a big bang at the end so
that's the way he made his peace and his
Adam says we then figured out the best
way to have him perform his piece it's
gonna be looked at by this camera
analyze his movements it's gonna let Dan
bring out all the different aspects of
his music that he wants to and you're
also going to notice a visual on the
screen we asked one of our students to
look at
what the cameras measuring so but
instead of making it very literal
showing you exactly the camera tracing
we turned it into a graphic that shows
you the basic movement and shows the way
it's being analyzed I think it gives an
understanding of how we're picking out
movement from what Dan's doing but I
think it'll also show you if you look at
that movement that when Dan makes music
his motions are very purposeful very
precise very disciplined and they're
also very beautiful
so in hearing this piece as I mentioned
before the most important thing is the
music's great and it'll show you who Dan
is so this is are we ready Adam yeah
okay now Dan will play his piece my
Eagle song for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
brother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you